The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: Let me tell you
what I've handed out to you.
My argument is that race
is the significant factor
in urban history
of South Africa.
I will justify that at
the beginning of my talk.
Secondly, the form of
Johannesburg from 1876 onwards
can be judged in terms of
the location of Black people
and attitudes
towards Black people.
Essentially, apartheid
as a philosophy
regarded cities as
violently against the norm,
which would keep Black people in
rural or semi-rural situations
by tribe.
There's an old colonial method
of dealing with the population.
And that's by keeping them
in a tribal situation.
The city, at its
most magnificent,
is an educative instrument,
an enabler of change.
Change is what South
Africa was trying to avoid.
That is the hegemony of white
people over Black people.
And the city becomes a
phenomenally important
instrument.
I will try to take
you through the five
stages of South African urbanism
in the case of Johannesburg--
the mining camp from 1876--
well, 1885 to 1917, the informal
city, the rationalized city,
the regional city, and
the current open city,
post-apartheid city.
I will look at the detail in the
second city, the informal city.
That is of a township called
Western Native Township,
which consisted of
15,000 people living
in 2,000 houses, the
first public housing
buildings in Johannesburg
during the influenza epidemic.
Every time public
action takes place,
spatially it's in
a site which is
considered to be either a
dump site of some low value.
And often the decision occurs
because of some disease.
The first movement out of
the mining camp in 1904
occurs because of
the plague epidemic.
And who happens to be, in South
Africa, the most important man
ever to live in South Africa
even for a short time?
Who is that?
AUDIENCE: Mahatma Gandhi.
JULIAN BEINART: Gandhi.
Yes, of course.
Gandhi learnt his politics in
South Africa before returning
to India.
And he was in Johannesburg.
And the Indian township,
which was burnt down
because of the
plague, he interceded
with the Transvaal government
to allow the people to return
at night to dig in their
basements to retrieve gold
which they had stored away.
Anyway, Western Native Township
is the first publicly built
housing for Black people.
I want to examine it
from 1917 to 1965.
If those of you've read what
I've written about this,
the story of Western
Native Township
appeared on the cover of
three architectural magazines
in three parts of the
world in September 1966.
So it's a fairly
well-known story.
I'm repeating it
for the 999th time.
And I hope it's not
too boring for you.
The second page is a
summary of the location
of Black people over time.
You will see that
Black people are
moved from the center of the
city further outwards in one
vector towards the southwest.
The bar graphs below indicates--
when we look at this
slide, I'll indicate
some of these subtleties.
The solid black is
housing by the public.
The horizontal line is
housing by the private sector.
You will see at the
beginning of Soweto, the--
yeah, no.
I'll go to this in some detail.
I have to worry
about time because we
cover a lot of stuff.
The graph showing
cumulative housing built
indicates that the attempt to
marshall the Black population
in the city took an
enormous leap in number
from about 1950 onward.
This was the building
of the major part
of Soweto, population of
about 1.5 million people.
AUDIENCE: Is this is a
public housing building?
JULIAN BEINART: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah, sorry.
The next few pages deal with
Western Native Township.
These two pages which follow
are a little difficult
to follow, but deal
with the four stages
in the life and death of
this township in regard
to a number of things,
the social organization.
This research was done
from the Black newspapers,
which have a long tradition
in South African journalism.
Much of this data is transcribed
by one of my Black assistants
doing this work.
It's an extraordinarily
difficult piece of work to do.
We had to justify
some of the comments
about gangs, about
the origins of jazz
and so on, through
interview with older people
to justify some of it.
Although this is social
science research,
which approximates things
more than anything else.
The next page is a quote
from a book on fascism,
architectural fascism.
The paragraph which
I marked, I think,
explains the formal
declaration of this township
on the walls, which I will go
to into some detail with you,
as a piece of
reconstruction of nature.
And I think this paragraph,
which deals largely
with our classical
architecture works,
deal very well with the
issue of the facade.
And the last page
is just one example
of the facades of these houses.
So to return to the
beginning, racial segregation
underlies all urban
history in South Africa.
It's the most extreme version
of segregation based legally
on the basis of race.
Had South Africa not
legislated race legally,
the rest of the world
would have left it alone.
There's discrimination on the
basis of race in the American
South still today, although
the central government
has acted in civil rights
issues after many years of not
doing anything about it.
But in South Africa, from
the earliest times onwards,
there was a move reinforced
by the Dutch Reformed Church
to regard Blacks as
temporary inhabitants
although they were the
majority of the society.
In 1904, a government
white paper says,
"let them understand that
the towns of the colony
are the special birthplace and
abode for the white man who
are the governing race."
This is 1904.
My god, South Africa only
became a country in 1910.
This is under British rule,
British colonial rule.
1921, "it should be
understood that the town is
the European area in which
there is no place for the London
native, who neither works
nor serves his or her people.
The town is a white phenomenon.
Blacks only visit for
labor temporarily."
Between 1960 and 1985,
one person per minute
was prosecuted under the
Pass Laws in South Africa.
The Pass Laws required for
you to have work continuously
for 10 years for one
employer, for example.
If you were in the city and
couldn't fulfill that demand,
you're prosecuted
under Pass Laws.
So you have a white city
and a phenomenally migrant
population--
migrant not in their
own belief or judgment,
but in the judgment of a
hegemonous white population.
Black people are only
there to serve to serve
the whites in cities, 1921
In 1976, Mr. MC
Botha the minister
of Bantu Administration--
again, the use of
terminology is interesting.
Blacks, Bantu is a linguistic
group of languages.
The minister of
Bantu administration
could either be the minister
of Black administration,
the minister of
native education,
African education,
or the minister of
Azanian education.
It's one of these
independence group
named South African Blacks.
The use of the racial
denomination is interesting.
Because South Africa
traded with Japan,
Japanese were considered
white in South Africa.
Chinese were considered Black.
Colored people or
the miscegenous group
are considered Black, but
in this special category.
The whole idea is, if you
denominate the population
by tribal group, whites are
the superior race by number.
They beat the number of
Zulu people in South Africa.
So if you keep on categorizing
people as Zulu, Xhosa, Tswana,
Khoisan, whatever,
Ndebele, and so on,
you will break down the
society into tribal groups,
which the whites are
the superior group.
It's an incredibly interesting
and awful phenomenon,
which comes out of
this doctrine, whereby
the doctrine is that the city
is a polluting environment.
It causes people to change.
It educates people.
And that's frightening because
it educates people to move out
of hegemony of
tribalism where you
live according to
code of behavior
and moving to the cities where
they become industrial workers,
join trade unions, and are
open to political democracy.
So the South African
experience is fundamentally
important for those
of you who are
interested in the
details of policy
in order to maintain white--
migrant labor is a phenomenon
all over the world.
Abu Dhabi depends
on migrant labor.
So does Dubai.
The relationship between
Turkey and Germany
has, for a long time, been a
relationship of migrant labor.
India has a phenomenal use
of migrant labor still today,
an interesting aspect
of Indian urbanism.
AUDIENCE: Mexico to US.
JULIAN BEINART: Mexico
to US, absolutely.
I don't want to get into
a discussion of the values
or disvalues of migrant labor.
But in the South
African situation,
migrant labor was not only
labor from within South Africa,
but Black labor from
the adjoining countries,
from Zimbabwe, as far away as
Malawi on the basis of service
to the gold mining and
uranium mining industries,
keeping people outside of
the normal family situation,
living in hostels, being
paid money in order
for them to export the money
to the local poor origins.
The first city
occurred because gold--
as I said in a previous class,
Chicago and Johannesburg
were the two most important
cities of the 19th century.
People can argue.
You can postulate
some other candidates,
but which other city is
founded in the 19th century?
Athens was rebuilt
in the 19th century.
It was virtually nothing.
But new cities of
the 19th century, I
argue that Johannesburg
and Chicago are the two
significant examples.
Gold was discovered on the reef.
That's the ridge which
Johannesburg is built.
And the mining camp
which resulted in a plan
which I'll show you,
which has very small lots.
One of the reasons for making
small lots in a mining camp
is that there are
many corner blocks.
The corners go to bars.
So you make small lots.
Whenever you have to choose a
lot size, the bigger the lot,
the fewer corners there are.
So you can look at
the plan of Manhattan
in terms of the
number of corners
there are in the
geometry and calculate
how valuable it would have been
had the blocks being shorter
in length.
Léon Krier, whose work we'll
discuss in a few weeks' time,
argues in his plan for Barcelona
the subdivision of the Cerdá
block of 1,000 into 3,000 or
3 times 300 or 4 times 250.
Tel Aviv has very small blocks.
It has enormous
traffic problems caused
by the blocks are too small.
Traffic conditions
are bad enough
in Manhattan given the long
length of the blocks east-west,
but we're not talking about
Manhattan at the moment.
Gold attracts
people very quickly.
And 10 years after
Johannesburg's birth,
there were 100,000
people in the city.
50% were Black, Africans,
Malays, coloreds, Indians,
and Chinese.
Each of these groups was located
in what is called a location.
A location is a
British colonial term
for locating people whom
you consider to be workers.
And generally, they are Black or
colored in some form or other.
We find locations in
Zimbabwe and Kenya
and other parts
of Africa as well.
This was a city of primitive
feudal social relationship.
There was a Bantu--
there was a Kaffir location.
Again, remember, look at
the word, the terminology.
Kaffir an Arab word which
refers to bad people.
Coolie, what does the word
coolie in Indian mean?
AUDIENCE: It's a worker.
JULIAN BEINART:
What does it mean?
AUDIENCE: It's a worker.
JULIAN BEINART: A worker,
but it's a pejorative word.
I grew up in South Africa.
And I remember buying fruit
from the coolie store.
Language indicates intention
fairly well in urbanism.
One should be careful what
we word, how we name, things.
Numbering street by number
has some implication.
Calling a street Merrymount
Street has other implications.
We shouldn't take
this too seriously.
This city ends with the disease.
The plague, in 1904, forces the
Emancipation of Black people
immediately out of the
Black, the Kaffir location
to the site of the
Anglo-Boer war camp
15 kilometers to the southwest.
And that's the origin of Soweto.
It's a town called Pimville
where Miriam Makeba comes from,
a famous Black South
African singer.
And she's known as
Pimm's Number 1.
Pimm's Number 1 refers
to a British drink.
I'm getting too
sophisticated here,
playing games with language.
1917 to 1948, the informal city,
it begins with the influenza
epidemic of 1917.
The cities now face to house
Blacks for the first time.
Next to the municipal
dump, it chooses
to develop Western
Native Township.
The annual expenditure
on Black housing
is the same as the annual
budget for the zoo.
Sophiatown, which is a private
enterprise environment.
The cornation formed
the western areas.
This is the
equivalent of Harlem.
It was where African
music, journalism,
African political parties, the
cooperative movement, gangs,
the nexus of Black
culture develops
in an extraordinary period
of time of about 30 years.
Sophiatown is free held.
At that time, about 50% of
Black housing is private.
50% is public.
It's the city of
informal relationships.
There's shared shopping on the
seams, generally Indian shops.
There's a strong self-help
identity and many journey
to work options,
including walking to work.
The informal cities have
become enormously overcrowded
with South Africa's
industrialization
in the '39, '45 war
and the South African
so-called liberal
political parties defeated
in the '48 elections, replaced
by the Afrikaner National
Party.
The Afrikaner National Party--
driven by a number of
fundamentalist initiatives.
The word [AFRIKAANS],, which
is Afrikaans for Black danger,
is a term which is employed
to threaten white South
Africans that the
Blacks, who are
the majority of the
population, will
destroy the white population
and white civilization.
White civilization
is promoted to the--
South African whites produced
bad German opera whilst Blacks
were playing jazz based on
American music and music which
they understood politically.
I was part of the South African
jazz movement for a while
because I had a lot
of jazz material
from America when I
was in graduate school.
And it contrasts, again,
the informal popular notion
of music which, in the
South African case,
in the South African
Black case, migrates
from playing the
penny whistle, which
is a very primitive
instrument, to the saxophone.
South African jazz musicians
played the alto saxophone
more than they played
the trumpet, again,
for reasons of
choice, which based
on the kind of
musical vibrations
that those instruments
gave to them.
The whites emulated badly
classical Western German music.
So you have, in the
Western areas, the growth
of informal movement.
I regard the declaration system
in Western Native Township,
which we'll discuss
in a few minutes,
as a popular phenomenon,
which people use to make--
well, let's wait
until we get there.
The notion that Blacks
are a rural people
is manifest in
apartheid religion.
It allows one to believe that
Blacks should be returned
to rural tribal existence.
Public housing is built at
low densities, no elevators.
Blacks are racially
subdivided into tribes
in the new apartheid regime.
Soweto, Western Native
Township, as you will see,
did not separate
people by tribe.
This was in the setting
of the informal city.
And apartheid Soweto was
allocated into separate ghettos
of tribal entity.
Houses were built,
so that people
could be seen as rural people.
The house in Western
Native Township
was about 250 square feet.
It had seven people in it.
It had a porch of
100 square feet.
The porch was where
people at sundown
should sit and watch
the sun go down
or the sunrise in the morning.
It is absolute nonsense
to build housing
at that density
with an open porch.
No wonder that was
70% of the porches
were enclosed, as we will see
in the process of the changes
to the house, adding 100
square foot to the house.
There are a couple of other
pieces to the apartheid story.
Between 1955 and
1960, 33,000 houses
were built, twice as many
as in the previous 37 years.
The effort houses a quarter
million people in five years.
In the Johannesburg
brochure, it talks
about it being the biggest
housing project in the world.
Why were the houses
not mass-produced?
Why are they houses built
of bricks and tin roofs?
AUDIENCE: The were hotels?
JULIAN BEINART: Hum?
AUDIENCE: So they
were built as hotels?
JULIAN BEINART: Not quite,
but it has to do with labor.
The Bantu Building Act
eliminated Black labor
from the white
building industry.
Therefore, Black labor could
only build for Black houses.
In 1947, in Jabavu
building costs
were 1 rand per square foot.
It dropped to $0.60 per square
foot during the apartheid era.
No industrialized building,
only laying bricks--
the third city is a city of
total insulation, isolation.
In Soweto, population of
1.5 million with few shops,
hardly any entertainment,
the journey
to work cost 300% more
than in the second city,
total reliance on the white
central business district.
In the study of the
white central business
district of Johannesburg,
I was always
puzzled by why some of the most
expensive men's clothing stores
were next to the railway
station for Blacks.
And jazz records, the best
record stores, were close by.
If you have 1.5 million
people whom you isolate,
there's no apartheid in
the selling of goods.
There is only apartheid
in where you live
and where you go to school
and what your relationship
with between race.
Shopping is kept open
to multiracial endeavor.
The market works that way.
So where do the
expensive stores, which
can use the 19th century
train system from Soweto
to Johannesburg,
where do they locate?
They locate very close to
the Black railway station.
Very briefly, because we have
to look at a lot of material--
by 1970, the effort
which produced Soweto
could not be sustained.
There was no more public
housing built after 1970.
A new urban regional
pattern was conceived of.
That is to create a set
of tribal enclaves called
Bantustans, mainly for the
largest for the Zulu and Xhosa,
the Xhosa in the
Eastern Cape province,
the Zulu in the
Natal, the Tswana,
the only free state in
the Transvaal provinces.
The idea would be to induce
within centers factories
to locate on the borders
of these Bantustans,
again, in an attempt to
frustrate urbanization.
So the pattern of
the new regional city
would have industries
moving out of Johannesburg
locating on the
edges of a Bantustan
a couple of hundred miles away.
This is the same nonsense
as the empowerment zones
under the Clinton
Administration in this country,
that you could induce with
the incentives industry.
Industry nourishes
itself on urbanization.
There are reasons industry
are in dense cities, not in--
by and large, in dense cities.
Decentralized industry occurs
under special conditions
as well.
But the notion that you pay
industry special margins
in order to locate, in order to
maintain Blacks in rural areas
as tribes, is a fantasy only
to be concocted by a regionally
illiterate mind.
At one point, South
Africa was contemplating
getting the Japanese
to build a monorail,
to build a train line, from
the Zulu areas in Natal
500 miles to Johannesburg, so
that the industry could locate.
The famous story of David
Goldblatt's photographs
of 3 times 8, a
Black laborer who
lives in the Ndebele Bantustan
and works in Johannesburg,
spend 8 hours a day commuting,
8 hour day sleeping,
and 8 hour a day working.
One third of his day is
spent in commutation by bus.
Of course, the system blew up.
It blew up for a
number of reasons.
It blew up because there
were some important figures
involved.
It would not have occurred,
the new fifth city
would not have occurred,
had the ANC not--
there's a long story
behind all of this, which
I haven't got time to tell you.
But one day, if
you're interested,
I'll tell you about Margaret
Thatcher's involvement
with South Africa liberalism.
She just died this week.
She shouldn't be
venerated so much.
She was one of the few agents
who supported the South
African white government.
South Africa--
the United States,
of course, it
boycotted South Africa.
And SANOC, the South African
National Olympic Committee
had got South Africa kicked
out of the Olympic games.
In a sport-obsessed society,
such as South Africa,
it was as much rocked by
international punitive actions
against it taking part
in international sport.
But Maggie Thatcher, in
the end, couldn't convince
the rest of the world--
South Africa depends
on foreign investment.
And Maggie Thatcher
finally told Mr.--
whoever the white South African
prime minister was the time
that she couldn't any longer
support the ANC, the African
National--
forgive me.
It's a long story.
Let's say South Africa changed.
And let's look at
Western Native Township
because we can learn something
from the environment of housing
by looking in detail at housing.
There are 5,000--
2,000 houses of different
types with 80% of them
about 250 square feet.
The house is about 20 feet by
20 feet in dimensions with an 8
by 12 porch.
Over time, people changed
their houses, firstly,
enclosing the porch.
Well, firstly, in a very
tribal fashioned manner,
the first residents
who appeared in 1917
still had cows roaming
around the premises.
The first act was to decorate
the front of their houses.
The fronts of their
houses were always
decorated, never the
sides or the back.
The house didn't have
an internal toilet.
The toilet was on the
back of the house.
The first attempt to--
the houses were two rooms plus
a porch with a outfit for a coal
stove in the first room.
The first inhabitants
reacted to their houses
the way they acted to
tribal circumstances.
They used mud and [NON-ENGLISH]
decoration systems which you
scrape a pattern in the
mud and use cow dung to--
the house had no ceilings,
had no floors, had no gates.
It was about the most
primitive, cheap item
that the society could produce.
Over time, the enclosure
of the porch started.
It started by people
buying rubbish material
from Indian shops, old
ceiling tiles, thrown away
wood, some glass, and enclosed
the porches in this way.
You'll see them in
the photographs.
This was dangerous.
Fires broke out.
And the magistrate,
in his intelligence,
proclaimed that the
people who had enclosed
the porches innocent, saying
that under such density
you couldn't blame people
for making more space.
He argued, however, that
the future decoration
and enclosures should be
more permanent and more safe.
From that time onwards,
the permanent decorations
took place.
These decorations form
interesting for a number of--
you will see them.
I don't know if you've
seen them before.
First of all, the
decorations are only
on the fronts of the houses.
We only decorate the front
of our houses as well.
There's no house in Newton
which has a decorated backyard.
It has an antebellum facade.
Number two, the houses are
not free drawn decorations.
There's a communal language
which is created in order to--
so everybody decorates according
to a communal language.
The language consists
of rectangular systems,
circular systems, sun-dried
systems, and half-moon systems.
Most often refer ambiguously
to the past and the present.
When I talked to a woman
about why she used a circle
on her house, she says to me--
and it's mainly the
women who decide
what the decorations are.
She says to me,
look, you're smoking.
The ashtray you're
using is circular.
It's modern.
Another woman says, when
you grow up in the country,
you live on a flat plane.
You see the sun rising.
Therefore, a half-circle
decoration is the sun rising
or is the sun setting.
So there's a syncretism
between rural and urban.
It's almost as if the
decorative system manages
to nourish people both
in terms of the origins
and their past and the future
that they see in the city.
The city is allowing
them to migrate
as individuals and as a
society from a rural society
to an urban society.
Some of their houses,
as I will show you,
try to emulate white
middle-class houses.
There's an expensive suburb of
Johannesburg called Houghton,
H-O-U-G-H-T-O-N. There's a
house called Hoyton in Western
H-O-Y-T-O-N.
There's something miraculous
about a system of this kind,
a communally agreed upon system.
This is where the first
self-help community
organizations occurred in
Black South African cities.
Another interesting thing is
that you use abstract forms
to depict real situations.
So if the fafi game, which
is a Chinese gambling game,
is played intensively
in this environment--
there are 32 symbols.
I think 32 or 24.
A woman who runs a
fafi saloon does--
I'll show you the image.
There's a half-arch form on
the outside of her house.
If you look at it
carefully, she says to me,
you will see it's a horse.
A horse was my lucky symbol.
It doesn't look
like a horse at all.
The communist chairman of
the first ANC Transvaal group
puts a circle on this house with
a serrated edge to the circle.
When you ask him why
he first uses this,
he says, that's a
Stalinist image.
It promotes industry.
There's a whole set--
I will show you two of them--
of decorations which are based
on the rectangular family which
become blades.
Why blades?
Because razor blades
was, you know--
people were killed
regularly in this township.
There was a lot of violence,
a lot of gang warfare.
So blades become another form.
But a blade, what is
a razor blade made of?
It's made of three circles--
a primitive razor blade--
and a rectangular outline.
The genius of being able to
conform to a communal language
and yet express your
particular message
is what a city should be like.
You should be able to promote
your individual experience,
but live within a
communal language.
At least that's the way I would
describe the formal attributes
of a good city.
Don't quote me on that.
There are a lot of byproducts.
Let me just mention one or
two for you to think about.
The notion of the popular--
the poetics of the
popular occur when
you see African popular
art is extensive
and ranges all the way
from tombstones in Nigeria
to wall paintings to barbershop
advertisements and so on.
The popular large margin
of freedom in people
to express themselves without
the classical requirements
of orthodoxy, it bends things.
It changes things.
Again, I refer you back to
the definition of classicism
in this paragraph I isolated.
Just before we look
at the slide images,
Let me see if I want to focus
your attention on anything
else.
The role of the popular
decoration is externalization--
the idea of the gaze, the
idea of the house looking out
on the street.
OK, I think this is--
when I first showed this
material in London many years
ago at the Institute of
Contemporary Art in London,
somebody in the audience
stood up and said,
was I sharing this work as if
these were drawings on ghetto
walls, would I make an
exhibition of Jewish markings
on Nazi war camps?
I had always seen this
and experienced this work
as optimistic, as
showing that people
under extreme deprivation still
have an image of responding
to the city through
educating themselves,
through externalizing
themselves,
through communalizing and so on.
And it's curious
that the relationship
between deprivation
and resistance
should be seen as negative, but
I can understand the argument
as well.
Does the popularization of
items done by poor people
and sold as tourist
goods enable or--
it helps them economically?
Does it improve their culture?
Who knows?
We can debate these issues.
I think the issue of
deprivation and resistance
has the fundamental
aspect of an iconography
of fascinating topics.
I was surprised--
I didn't know how
to answer the
gentleman who asked--
who assaulted me in London.
I've never been assaulted since.
This material has been shared
widely as part of the BBC film.
And let's look at this stuff.
I think the marginal quality of
things in an urban environment
is the grease which
allows people often
to engage marginally
in an activity.
They cannot build
their own houses.
They cannot select a house
under the Group Areas Act.
These people decorated
their houses every year,
despite the fact that
they were renters.
They assumed permanent
ownership despite being
renters because they
were there for 25 years.
They never assumed that
they would be moved out.
So the notion of the popular,
the notion of a fluid system
which is generated in a city,
is an interesting idea to me.
Because the prismatic quality
of identifying separate items
in a city, the situationist's
view of the city,
is interesting in that regard.
G. Debord's notion of
Paris as being made up
of fluid communities
and Towards Cosmopolis
book of the other, the new
migrant environment in cities
of permanent migrations
is interesting,
but we'll touch on these
subjects a bit later.
And let's look at
pictures instead.
It's much more refreshing.
OK.
Turn off the lights.
The analysis on
the right indicates
the move towards the southwest.
The horizontal lines
are the public sector.
In the early stages of the
city, the mining companies
provide housing in this
Sophiatown housing.
As soon as the supply of Black
is too small for the market,
you have these white
dots, squatter settlements
take place at the beginning
of the apartheid city.
Because the demand, the supply
of white housing is, too.
And soon, the white housing
is completely-- at least
the market housing is
completely eliminated.
And Soweto, which is
these two black volumes,
creates a second city.
Next, this is the mining camp.
Here's the Kaffir location--
there's no embarrassment
about using the word Kaffir--
next to the Coolie occasion.
The Coolie location is
where the plague broke out
and Gandhi intervened.
Here are the small blocks
of the white mining camp.
Next.
The third city, Soweto--
an engineer's madness.
All houses are built like huts.
The notion that Blacks in
Harlem in the United States
are crime ridden
and dense housing
produces criminal
behavior is sold
as part of the nationalist
government's orthodoxy.
You can see the
only public space
are large tracts of green
space with a few isolated.
There is no central
business area.
There are few schools.
Whatever it looks like, it is.
Next.
The building of Soweto
starts with Pimville in 1904.
The public supply
of Black housing
increases slowly, but
has incredible spike
with the advent of the
nationalist government in 1948.
So from this point onwards, the
whole governmental apparatus
both at the national
and at the city
level is oriented toward the
application of the Group Areas
Act, the Pass Laws.
The Johannesburg City
Council passed 96 acts
dealing with the Black people
in each city in the few years
of this second, third city.
Next.
The tallest building
in Africa, 52 floors,
one of the tallest concrete
buildings in the world,
was designed by Skidmore,
Owings, and Merrill
with separate toilets
for whites and Blacks.
So when I was visiting--
were invited by the students
to come and give a lecture,
when they were asked by students
how they could design toilets
for whites and
Blacks separately,
they were embarrassed
and said, well, you know,
you have to work where you--
the gold mining dumps are
part of the landscape.
Next.
The depiction of
the center of city,
this is the drawing
for Charles Center,
all depicting white
people as the--
more and more, at the same
time, the everyday environment
was that of Black people.
Next.
Soweto produced,
amongst its horrors,
the use of a 19th
century fixed-line rail
system and a bus system
to take people to work.
Here's a line
waiting for a train.
Springs is a suburb
of Johannesburg.
"Whites only to springs."
It's a bit strange
to look at this.
If you grew up in South Africa,
this is what you grew up with.
And it's amazing how
striking it seems now.
Next.
1976, the famous shooting
of this young Black boy
by the police in this riot
against Bantu education,
one of the beginnings of the
collapse of the rational city.
Next.
I just put in this diagram
of somebody's approximation
of apartheid city.
And sector theory
of Homer Hoyt--
which we referred to a couple
of months ago in this class.
The theory of Hoyt referred to
the American city segregating
itself out in terms of
sectors, sectors moving,
in the case of Johannesburg,
in the opposite direction
as Blacks.
Blacks in the
industry always are
in the south or the southwest.
Whites always are in the
north, moving northwards.
Next.
These areas here, this is
this Ciskei and the Transkei.
And this is the Ciskei
and the Transkei
and Zululand and Botswana.
And these are the Bantustans.
Here is the notion of treating
a rural population as rural,
maintaining the
rurality, but arguing
that industry should located
on the perimeter using
this local population.
This uses strange terms.
Deconcentration points, what's
a deconcentration point?
Industrial development
to deconcentration points
in national states, I mean,
this is like Nazi language.
I mean, you know,
planning language.
Excuse me for getting a little
sentimental about all of this.
Next.
Western Native Township--
2,000 houses, different
types of houses, but largely
250 square feet.
I'll just point out to you
a couple of other things.
These black lines
running horizontally,
what this community
spontaneously does,
if the block size is too large,
the house becomes a passageway.
There are rituals.
You knock on the door.
You pass through.
And you say hello to
the woman of the house,
and you walk out to
the back of the house.
There are a number of
community institutions.
There are shebeens, which
are illegal drinking--
alcohol is barred
to Black people
entirely under apartheid.
You could only
drink kaffir beer,
which was sold by the
government to get great profit.
A stokvels is an ongoing party.
There are all of these
self-help institutions,
which are part of the popular
culture place of this kind.
Next.
Here is the house as
provided to the people.
Next.
A number of types of
house, it's a bit wrong.
Almost 80% of the
houses were type B
without the additional
dotted area at the top.
Type B is this plus that
if your porch is enclosed.
It's 250 plus 100.
This is analysis of
the walls of the house.
These solid black
indicates that the porch
is enclosed and decorated.
The hollow circles
are where the porch
is enclosed, but not decorated.
The empty lots are
nothing has happened.
You can see the
intensity of decoration
is larger in this
area of the township,
large close to the outside
and entrance to the area
and, also, because some of
the prominent families lived
in this area.
Next.
That's just what I've
tried to explain.
This is the density
of decoration.
And this is the breakdown
of facing street
in terms of tribe.
I think yellow is Tswana.
Blue is Zulu.
And three is Tsonga.
And four, I think, is Xhosa.
Five is Ndebele and so on.
Next.
The result is that
the street is made up
of a consistent
iconography, circles,
sun systems, and
other sun systems,
a half-arch plus circles.
This is an undecorated house.
In addition to changing
the face of the house,
the external environment of
the fences, the mail delivery
options, gates, trees
are added to the city.
Next.
Here is the original
response on the left,
mud and using a
fork or your fingers
to make traditional decoration.
On the second is
the second attempt
to enclose the porch
using throwaway material.
Next.
You can see everything
is taken into account
from the mail delivery
point through to floor
polish zone, a garden,
two half-gardens.
The porch is not
enclosed in this case,
but is made into
an outdoor room.
The major wall is
decorated by a rising sun.
You can see the
architectural ideas,
which would make an architect
like Louis Kahn proud.
Here is an example of
a sun system embracing
the whole of the thing.
The porch is enclosed.
There's a little--
one of the problems
was that this porch was always
asymmetrical in a facade.
Here is a permanently parked
automobile as an external room.
An interesting idea, you could
actually use an automobile
as a living room.
I think a Lexus
automobile attempts
to be a living room,
but a mobile one.
I think it would be interesting
in if we ever got to the state
where we are to regard
Lexus as permanent.
Next.
Two other examples-- here's
a razor blade phenomenon.
AUDIENCE: Which one's
the razor blade?
JULIAN BEINART: The green.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
I see.
Yeah.
JULIAN BEINART: There's
a version of it,
a more abstracted version, and
the more literal version of it
there on top of which is a gable
and a classical attempt to--
the sunrise of the gate.
There's sunrise gates
all over the world.
I know with the sunrise--
I suppose, if you're
interested in heliocentricity.
When I once showed
this material,
a man who was an
Egyptian heliocentrist
said that this was all a
subliminal sun devotion system.
I don't understand that.
Next.
Here are rectangular forms.
You find this in Florence in
decorative wooden wall systems.
The old idea in
heliocentricity is
that this is a skin
which is pinned down
in the four corners, allowing
these quarter circle set backs.
The architectural
problem was often
dealing with the asymmetry
between the two sides.
Next.
Here the large
form of the facade
is reproduced in the mailboxes.
On the other side
is a combination
of the rectangular system
with a circular system.
Next.
Difference in material--
this is all cheap concrete.
The two circles-- next.
The use of the color of the back
wall of the main facade wall
and the floating of a
rectangular texture on it
leaving the four circles in
the background is predominant.
Next.
Here's the razor blade.
Three circles, four empty
circles and a rectangle
constitutes a razor blade.
On the right-hand side
is another version
of the razor blade.
We saw in the drawing.
Next.
The fafi saloon lady elephant
on the-- or horse I think it
is on the right And the
communist industrial rotor
for the ANC leader on the right.
AUDIENCE: There are some colors
that keep repeating themselves,
like this light blue--
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --kind of
pistachio even and this light
terracotta--
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --is there a
preference in the color
that they use?
JULIAN BEINART: No,
not that I can answer.
The trouble was that,
during the period
that we studied
this community, I
got to know this community
through the Jazz movement,
by taking Black
musicians home at night.
And one night, the lights
shone on these walls.
And I said, my god, something
strange is happening here.
I never been here.
Whites don't go to
Black townships,
not at that time in
South Africa's history.
It was too dangerous.
So by the time I
got involved in this
was in protests which was
starting against the removal
of Blacks from Sophiatown.
So the demolition of Sophiatown
caused enormous Black anger.
And I was one of the
people who was there
as a supposedly urbanist.
And I came back to
Western Native Township
when the people were
starting to be moved out.
And colored people
were being moved in
to replace the Black
people as temporary houses.
Some of the color system is
over painted by colored people
on top of the Black people.
I have no record of
what this thing looked
like 10 years before.
Nobody has.
This is the only
record that exists.
So I would have to guess.
I think the colors would
be more restrained.
I think the color
over painting--
you'd see pink and
bright colors--
is probably not the
colors that we used.
Next.
This is an example of
the problem of symmetry.
This is the halfway
line in the facade
and this incredible
architectural move
of marking the center of
the facade by a color shift
and still then using these
identical forms on either side.
Next.
The half-circle-- again
explained consistently
as the sunrise or sunset.
Next.
The sun itself takes many forms.
That pink is a colored
painting, over-painting.
One could do a study of the
colored temporary migration
before.
This township doesn't
exist anymore.
It's gone.
The coloreds who moved in
is a temporary phenomenon.
AUDIENCE: So each inhabitant
of the house usually
would design
completely their own?
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, generally, the
woman in the house.
AUDIENCE: I see that.
JULIAN BEINART: The
husband was either
too busy drinking
or earning a living
or being a member of
a gang or whatever.
The women in this--
this is a very
matrilineal society.
The people I spoke
to who seemed to know
most about the decoration
of the houses were women.
And often, if I asked why did
you choose the sun system,
the answer would be the
sun represents hope.
Or where I grew
up in the country,
I saw the sunrise every morning.
You know, what do you
expect people to say?
If I were to ask you why you
have a painting in your house,
you say, I like Piero della
Francesca, or I prefer Uccello.
Or I happen to have a Picasso
because my mother gave it
to me when I was a child.
Does somebody, say, give you
analysis of Picasso's painting?
Why do you expect these people
to know more about the way?
Next.
Two houses nearby-- these are
white middle class houses,
low white income, middle houses.
They are often referred to
as models for these people
to look at as a symbol
of improvement--
next-- whereas they
come from an environment
in their own countryside.
This is a Ndebele decoration
on the left and Zulu decoration
on the right.
Could you just turn on
the light at the back?
AUDIENCE: The last one is a
book of all this research?
JULIAN BEINART: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: The last slide
was a book of this research?
JULIAN BEINART: No,
it was published.
It's been published extensively.
I never wrote a book
because I'm too lazy--
[LAUGHTER]
--to write books.
I write long articles
instead of books.
Books are--
AUDIENCE: Was that normal?
JULIAN BEINART: It was
in Edilizia Moderna,
a special issue on
Africa, which I edited.
This appears in a number
of different forms.
The piece, which I gave you
in the required reading,
is good enough.
And it's got enough of
what I've said today in it.
It's an endless story.
I mean, what interests
me more is your reaction
to this material than
the material itself.
I mean can you enlarge
on this phenomenon
where does it make you
think of In Soweto, people
don't decorate the external
public facades anymore.
They become like all of you.
They buy expensive overstuffed
furniture and the television
set.
They've interiorized the
environment as we have.
Nobody in Manhattan cares
about the public facade
of the apartment block except
for the way you enter it.
You've got to have a canopy
and a man dressed up in uniform
for it to be expensive.
So we all have notions of
explicating our status.
If we were in a tribe,
in an urban tribe,
in a ghetto and had some
way of wanting to improve
our conditions, there's--
remember, there were seven
people in these two rooms.
And sometimes there were
additional items as well of
space.
But 80% of the houses
had about two rooms.
I think it's a very positive
enlarging phenomenon
that people have the capacity--
we regard children as having
the capacity to demonstrate
something unique when
they do drawings.
That capacity is lost
as we become adults.
You could say these
people are naive.
They are primitive.
They still have the
courage or whatever
it is to do something naive
in front of their house.
To them, it wasn't naive.
But it raises the
issue of the popular
in the urban phenomenon.
And it's, I think,
an extraordinarily
interesting and
important concept.
Why this received such
publicity when it was published
and I was giving lectures
all over the place
was because people like
John Turner here at MIT,
[? Jonah Brockin ?] in
Hartland before he came to MIT,
were talking about
changeable structures.
[? Jonah Brockin ?] book
says that indwelling
is a creative
phenomenon, that we only
need to build supports
for people who
can finish products themselves.
Individuation, expression
of individual identity,
all of these meaningful
items in urbanism
are what this raises for me.
South Africa is an extreme case.
If this were class
in pathology, it
would be like showing a case
of a dying cancer patient.
Look at the extreme.
There is no more extreme
public doctrine of racialism
as in South Africa.
And this is the response.
This is one of the responses.
Hundreds of thousands of people
died in that regime as well.
But I don't know.
What I can suggest is that you
think about this phenomenon
and transported into your own
understanding of the cities
that you live in and deal
with and make plans for.
If only everybody in the
world had the capacity
to react in this
positive way to--
our cities would look different.